Let's go instead to our caller from the two,
four, eight area code.
Who's calling today from two, four, eight,
right?
David?
My name is drew and else.
Hey, how's it going?
Can you had a, so I actually work in the Boston
area now, so I'm like originally from Michigan,
so yeah, it's nice to talk to a local Boston
now.
What's on your mind?
All right, so I just had to, I just wonder
your opinion on the kind of how news is being
shared differently now compared to like our
parents' age where they got their information
from MSNBC or like Fox News.
Uh, my parents are really like into CNN and
MSNBC.
Uh, what do you think of like the new progressive
left voice on Youtube?
While it kind of seemed like the right rd.
It did have a voice with like Steven Crowder,
Joe Rogan and stuff like that.
A lot of my friends are into Joe Rogan and
like find his views on things very uh, you
know, casual, like moderate I guess in a sense.
Hmm.
So do you feel like, um, that kind of has
a leg up where if you kind of mentioned to
people, Hey, I listened to David Pacman, I
like the rational national, the young Turks,
they're kind of like, oh, that's like too
far left, too extreme.
Like
[inaudible] for the most part, right.
You know, none of us individually, I have
the name recognition where there is an immediate
connotation for bringing up, Oh, I listen
to David Pacman or whoever else.
I mean, I think what's important to understand
is that the right, so if you go back and look
at a lot of the academic literature about
am radio and talk radio, the right effectively
had a monopoly on that platform from the get
go because structurally and because of the
relationship with regulators and the FCC,
the basically am talk radio was almost completely
right wing and religious for a very, very
long time.
So one thing that we have to sort of disabuse
ourselves of is the idea that um, because
a platform
is,
uh, dominated or appears to be dominated by
one side now,
uh,
the idea that that platform is indefinitely
going to be the agenda setting platform.
I think, you know, we would all agree that
now the Internet has sort of taken a lot of
that power from a am radio and that things
do change over time.
Nothing stays the same.
So that's one thing just to understand.
So when we talk about what's going on right
now on youtube and internet media, it doesn't
mean that it's what's going to be going on
in a few years.
Now.
I would sort of challenge your contention
that that being said that the right has had
this big advantage on youtube and online from
the beginning podcasting it, the genesis of
podcasting I believe was much more a progressive
minded
okay
form than it was right wing.
Although there are plenty of important and
big right wing podcasts and I think on Youtube
it's an open question as to whether the left
or the right is dominating.
If you look at number of channels you might
get one answer.
If you look at total audience size you might
get a different answer.
So I think that that's, that's really a question
right now.
Yeah, I guess it's just Kinda like the, the
big names for like, uh, Joe Rogan and Steven
Crowder with their millions of subscribers
and kind of besides the young trips, I don't
really see other lefty voices that, um, kind
of have such a widespread audience.
Sure.
I mean, I think there's a couple of things
you understand what that one is that a lot
of those, um, a lot of the lefty channels
are growing.
I mean Kyle Kalinsky and I are both on track
to hit, you know, a million subscribers in
the not crazy, crazy future.
And so that, that's definitely going to be
a change.
Sam Channel is also doing really well, but
I think it's also important to understand
that there are channels that are, and people
who are really big, not because they necessarily
have developed those audiences upbeat, but
because they have been significantly pushed
by significant funding from entities and that
is much more common on the right than it is
on the left.
So I think we just have to really look at
those numbers with a grain of salt and really
kind of understand the broader context in
which they exist.
But here's the question I would have for you
either way, like we can't control how many
people are following right-wingers online.
I think you would agree.
All we can do is do the best content possible
as lefties and get as many people to be listening
to us and watching us as possible.
We can't control what they do, but we can
control what we do.
Hmm.
Yeah, I guess it was just kind of, it's hard
when everyone kind of sees, uh, Joe Rogan
or like some Carter just like joking like
cool guys that have like fun views and they
smoke weed and everything,
but it's harder than Crowder smoked weed.
I think that was a big argument.
In fact with Rogan.
Yeah.
Well I mean just for Joe, like that's like
kind of like, you know, he's like a chill
guy would probably bring some writing or ideas,
but like it's Kinda hard to say, hey, check
out like this David Pacman club to people
who are in that sphere.
And it's just kind of like, it's just worrisome
that like people find Joe Rogan more like
the norm.
I see.
When talking to people instead of like some
of the other voices I hear on Youtube.
So that's kind of like where my question came
from originally.
But I do point from what you've been saying.
Yeah.
I mean there's no question.
Brogan is definitely seen as sort of like
the every man and you can kind of get behind
a lot of what he says because he's just kind
of like another guy next door that you're
talking to you.
The truth is row.
The majority of Rogan's views are pretty much
left wing views, uh, but they're presented
in a style in which it's less obvious and
then every once in awhile he will drop in
something that seems kind of right to right
wing.
Okay.
Thank you for the call.
Really appreciate hearing from you.
Um, great to hear from callers in the Boston
area and hope to hear from you again in the
future